PAUL IRISH: I want to take
a few minutes of your time
to tell you about
some of the new things
that we're doing in the Chrome
DevTools specifically focused
on mobile.
But to do that, I
really want to take back
the clock like two years,
back before remote debugging.
Two years ago,
development for mobile
was something along
the lines of, OK.
Let's do it on desktop.
And then I'll come over, and
I'll kind of drag the window.
Yeah.
OK.
And then I'll pick up my device
and I'll type it in there.
OK.
I need to make a change.
I'll come back here.
And that, it's a very
slow iteration cycle,
and that just slows
you down and makes
it much harder to create
compelling content.
So we've been
thinking about this,
and we want to make
that much better.
We want those iteration
cycles to be really fast.
We want it to be as easy
to debug and develop
for mobile as it is on desktop.
And so I'm going to talk
about three things today.
First up, remote debugging.
We'll talk about the browser on
the device, the real experience
over there, and then
talk about bringing
some of those mobile
characteristics
onto the desktop,
and then bringing it
all into a development workflow
and making it fast and fluid.
So first up, remote debugging.
So I've got my phone right here.
And I want to remote debug it.
So what I'm going to do
is come up to the top
here, click on Chrome's Hot Dog
Menu, that's the official name.
And we'll go down to Tools, and
then down at the bottom down
here is Inspect Devices.
So that's what
we're going to do.
Now you see here that there's
a check box on Discover USB
Devices.
This is because the discovery
and communication for devices
to remote debug is now
inside Chrome completely.
You used to have to
download the Android SDK,
get the 80 to binary or
get a Chrome extension.
Forget all that.
You just plug in the device.
So I'll plug in mine now,
and [POPPING NOISES].
All right.
Cool.
It looks like on my phone I
have two different Chromes.
We have Chrome 32, Chrome 31.
I have two tabs open here.
I can do an inspection.
I can change which
tab is my active tab.
Reload and close.
I have a little bit of control.
And I want to actually
just open up a new tab.
So I'm going to just type
in a new URL right here,
and I'm going to go
to news.google.com.
OK.
So it opened up on my device,
and you can see it here.
And I have the DevTools.
Cool.
So I'm just going to-- this
is the actual DevTools.
It's working.
It's cool.
It's awesome.
And when I highlight you
can see-- can you see?
OK.
Probably not.
But I'd love to be
able to show you this.
And in fact, when we think
about remote debugging,
it's a lot of-- I
have my DevTools here
and my device down
here, and it's
a lot of switching
back and forth.
And we thought that there's
probably a better way
to bring what you're
looking at down here
and have it visible on the
screen where your tools are.
So we have right here
this little icon.
And this is a new feature
that we're unveiling today,
and it's called Screencast.
And we're able to bring the
screen onto the device right
here.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: So this
is a really cool.
All right.
So let's interact
with this page.
Let's search.
OK.
I'm going to just
click in Search,
and I'm going to
type Google Chrome.
You know what?
Typing with my thumbs
is really slow.
Keyboards are way faster.
Let's just switch
over to my keyword
here and finish this off.
Nice.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: All right.
So I can type.
I can click.
I can scroll.
I can scroll on my trackpad.
No problem.
I'm going to go over
to Images and do
my real favorite
feature, inspect element.
It works the way you want it to.
Just pick it with your mouse.
It works flawlessly.
Really nice.
So this is really cool stuff.
I also have full control here
of the back forward reload.
And I'm actually just going
to go to a different site.
Let's see.
I'm going to come back
here, focus this other tab,
and we'll bring that up.
So this is a cool site.
You might have seen it before.
It's a Beer Camp kind
of advertisement.
I'm going to go landscape to
make this a little bit better.
And one of the things
that I want to show
is that this is a
really cool site where
they have this flip-book effect.
The guys at nclud did
a great job on this.
But I imagine that it
was very hard to develop,
because what they're doing is
they're manipulating these CSS
3D transforms in 3D space and
kind of changing all this.
I want to show a new kind
of experimental feature
that we're still working on.
It's the Layers Panel.
So here now I'm able to identify
in 3D space what this is like.
So I get a live preview
of these layers.
You heard [? Tommy ?] talking
yesterday about layers,
and now I'm able
to see what they
look like in a 3D
representation.
Nice.
Yeah.
You like it?
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: Now they
said to look out
for the extra information,
and it tells you
quite a bit of stuff.
So right now we're
showing the position,
the size, why it was
composited, which is often
a really key piece
of information.
Also an estimate
on how much memory
it has, how many
paints have gone in.
So we're getting
a lot of insight,
especially into
something like the GPU
behavior on a device,
which thus far has
been kind of a black box.
All right.
So we come out of this.
So for USB debugging,
just plug it in.
Don't worry about ADB.
Don't worry about
Chrome extensions.
You're good.
The feature set that's
available on remote debugging
is the same very
powerful feature
set they use, too, on
desktop, all that stuff.
Timeline, memory, debugging,
all of it's there.
You can Screencast your
screen, interact with it,
inspect, type, click.
The clicks are
translated to touches.
It's exactly what
you would expect.
And port forwarding
is one more, but I'm
going to show that
a little bit later.
I wanted to ask, though-- OK.
So raise your hands if you
test your stuff on two devices.
Two devices.
Keep your hands raised if you
test yourself on 10 devices.
That's kind of a lot.
I understand.
But I imagine that for
everyone-- and congratulations
for all you 10 device people.
You guys are heroes.
That is serious work.
But I imagine that
everyone that-- there
are more than 10 devices
that come to your site.
Right?
It's hard for us to
evaluate compatibility
with all of those.
So remote debugging is very
powerful for understanding
performance characteristics,
network conditions, things
like that.
But we can't do that for
every possible device
that we need to check
compatibility against.
So on Chrome DevTools
we've thought about this
and thought about
what we can do.
And so today I'm going to
show a new feature called
Mobile Emulation.
So this is some cool stuff,
and let me just show it to you.
I'm going to come
over here, and I'm
going to open up Wikipedia,
the article for the emulator.
And I'm interested in
doing some mobile--
I want to change how this is
represented on mobile devices
And so I'm just going to try
changing the screen size.
OK.
Unfortunately, this is not your
responsive kind of experience
that you want.
All right.
Let's open up DevTools.
Now down on the
bottom is a drawer.
You can access it
with this icon,
or you can just hit
escape to do that.
And you might be used to
seeing the console down here,
but there's a new
tab called Emulation.
Inside Emulation
there's a lot of stuff.
There's characteristics
for the screen resolution,
the devicePixelRatio,
autosizing, viewport,
user agent, Geolocation.
Good, good stuff.
There's a lot of things.
And so there's a few
device presets in here
that'll help set
all these at once.
So I'm actually just going
to choose this Nexus 4 here.
And it has a few viewport
settings of its own,
a devicePixelRatio
of 2 , a user agent,
and I'm just going
to turn on Emulation.
Now Wikipedia serves different
markup to mobile devices,
so I just need to
do a refresh first.
But yeah.
This is a little bit more
like what I'm expecting.
So a standard user
agent [INAUDIBLE]
would probably be able to
at least get the mark up
in CSS for this.
But we're doing a lot
more than just them.
First up, I can
scroll, and you can
see as I scroll the
contents for the pages,
I see it sliding
out of the viewport.
My cursor is changed
to this to indicate
that it is now a touch cursor.
And in fact, as I touch,
touch events are firing.
I can hold down Shift and
actually do a pinch, too.
So I can zoom just like you
would do with your fingers.
And this is the
exact same viewport
zooming that you
would see on a phone.
We put a lot of effort
into making sure
that the view here that
you see is as close as you
would see on a real device.
And so I'm going to try
to bring this over here
and just remote debug it.
I'll bring it up on my phone,
since I have one of these.
Screencast.
Hello.
And we'll come back to this.
And we're looking pretty good.
So there's a lot going in here.
And one of the things
that I want to point out
is that there are,
in some cases--
so you can see we're
enabling text autosizing
and also Android font metrics.
These font metrics are
something us developers are not
normally exposed to.
It turns out that
on Android WebKit--
and devices can actually
set a little fudge factor
to change the size of
how fonts are rendered.
This is never exposed to
us in CSS or JavaScript
or anything else like that,
but devices have this.
It mostly affects
sites that do not
have a meta viewport applied,
so kind of desktop sites
that are viewed.
But luckily, inside
Blink and WebKit,
we kind of know
what all these are.
So we just baked them
into the emulation
to make sure that the text that
you see inside Emulation mode
is as close as
possible as to what
you would see on
the actual device.
All right.
I'm going to come back here.
And I want to talk about
another feature that's in there.
It's devicePixelRatio.
So my MacBook Air is
not a retina machine.
It has a devicePixelRatio of 1.
In fact, we can see that here.
This page is just a
really basic demo.
It uses image set, and we
choose the kind of asset
based on the devicePixelRatio
of the device.
And so when I view
it on my machine,
it's just the 1x image
that's coming in.
I'm going to open up DevTools
and turn on the Emulation,
and we're seeing 2x.
So the devicePixelRatio
emulation captures all of this.
In fact, things
like image set act
exactly the way
you would expect.
Window.devicePixelRatio, any
devicePixelRatio meta queries,
all of that code that
everything goes through
on mobile browsers,
it's now going
through all of that
in the emulation
feature inside the
Chrome DevTools.
I took a look at a
few more other sites.
This is me with the Nexus S
emulating "The Boston Globe."
And I have an old Nexus S,
so I just brought that up,
looking pretty
sharp side by side.
And then I went flower shopping
for my mom for Thanksgiving.
Again, we're looking
very close now.
So that's the thing,
is that we really
think that having the
ability to emulate many
of the characteristics
of these mobile devices
saves you a lot of time.
And so you don't always have to
go down to your actual devices.
One more thing, this is kind
of an interesting situation.
This is the Chromium bug
tracker, as you can see.
And when I resize, it
just kind of sticks there.
But interestingly, you spend
a lot of time in your browser,
and you've experienced
desktop pages, especially
with fixed positioning.
And you zoom in.
I'm just doing a shift
pinch right here.
You'll notice this kind
of a thing happens.
This is a behavior that you
cannot really emulate normally
just by resizing the window.
And because we have
viewport emulation inside
of this feature, we can
really mimic the behavior
that you get on a phone.
So mobile emulation captures
your standard screen
resolution, the
devicePixelRatio, the text
autosizing behavior.
It happens mostly with
pages that they do not
have a meta viewport set.
The viewports, though,
this the viewport width
equals device width,
or you're setting up
something else, all of
that is now baked in here.
That's something that we haven't
been able to do on a desktop
before.
Touch events, of
course, including
synthetic gestures like
pinch, zoom, and pan,
and then your standard
user agent string, device,
geolocation, orientation
and that stuff.
I'm going to show one more here.
This is forecast.io.
Many people have probably
seen this site before.
Really nice,
well-developed site.
But it doesn't really-- my
standard approach would not
probably work here.
And even clicking
these menus and map,
it looks like they're only
bound with touch events.
So it's a little bit challenging
to approach this completely
on desktop.
So I'm going to go into
DevTools, turn on Emulation,
and just give it
a quick refresh.
And this is looking a lot
more like what I would expect.
I can swipe this out.
I can go into the menu.
Even go into the map,
and my touch move events
are behaving just
like I would expect.
All right.
So mobile emulation, it
can do a lot of things.
Emulate the rendering and
mobile characteristics
that you would get
on many devices
and have it right
here on desktop.
You can also see
what a retina would
look like on a
non-retina machine
and the vice versa,
and identify if you
have different assets coming
in for different pixel ratios.
Emulate that all right here.
All right.
Lastly, iterating quickly,
especially on mobile.
And to do this, I'm
going to launch a demo
and show a feature
called the Workspaces.
This is something that
we launched at Google I/O
earlier this year.
So I have a site coming up.
OK.
Cool.
HTML5 Please is the site.
But you can see I'm hosting
it off of a local host.
But I really want to do some
development on my phone.
So I can take this over and
go over to about inspect
and open up my tab.
And it's not-- come on.
Oh.
Right.
Local host 8000 on the
phone is the phone.
And the phone doesn't
have a web server on it.
So right.
OK.
Cool.
We'll come back here.
Yes.
Port forwarding.
OK.
Cool.
So let's forward the port.
So right here we're going to
forward my machine's local host
8000, send it over to
the device on its 8000.
We'll turn that guy on.
Done.
His green lights light up and
say, you're all good to go,
and let's try this again.
Refresh.
Nice.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: All right.
Cool.
So I have my local project, and
I want to make some changes.
I'm just going to inspect
element on my phone.
And we're going
to come down here.
And it looks like,
actually, these styles
are coming in from
Sass right here.
And with Sass we have
source map support.
So actually if I just
hold down Command,
I can click on this
property, and we'll
go to the original location
in the authored source
where that background
was defined.
So it's actually in a mixin.
The color looks like it's
coming in as a variable.
Let's jump out and Command
click on the color this time.
OK.
Cool.
This is the variable file.
And the color is
defined right down here.
And I want to change
it a little bit,
so let's lighten
it up just a touch.
I'll type "lighten,"
and we'll go for 20%.
And I'll just hit Save.
Nice.
Cool.
What do you think?
50%?
A little bit more?
Or we could darken it back up.
Yeah.
That's good.
Nice.
So what we're doing here
is that I'm typing Sass.
I'm hitting save
inside the DevTools,
because I just navigated
right over from style pane
to my original author code.
I'm hitting Save.
I'm getting a recompilation
of that Sass into the CSS.
And DevTools is like, hey,
you just changed your CSS.
Let me show it to you.
OK.
Cool.
So that's pretty good.
And this looks good to me.
I'm going to change one more
thing about this behavior
while I'm here on my phone.
This text box, it's
cool, but it needs
a little bit of spicing up.
So I'm going to improve
things a little bit.
I'm going to jump into the
script file and hit Command O
and jump into script.js.
And I know the function that
I want to take a look at,
so I'm going to hit Command
Shift O and dive into update
search.
I'm going to add in one little,
small piece of functionality
here.
I'm just going to tweak
things every time I
type into the search box.
Wow.
WebKitTransform.
The prefixes are on their way.
We're working on it.
All right.
So this looks good to me.
Math.random()360.
I think it's going to be great.
So what I'm doing
is I just finished
typing that script out.
I'm just going to hit Save.
And when I hit Save, the
new function definition
gets sent to V8,
and V8's like, Oh.
New.
Got it.
Cool.
I'm not refreshing
the page, but I'm
going to just come over
here and start typing.
And all right.
Nice.
An improvement.
Right?
I think so.
But this is really nice.
I just updated the Sass,
had it show up live.
I just undid the JavaScript.
It evaluated live.
I didn't refresh the page at
all, and I'm going really fast.
I'm liking what I'm
doing so much that I'm
going to come over here.
Let's get diff.
Yeah.
I just remote debugged my
phone, made these changes over
on my phone.
I mean I'm seeing it
here on my screen,
but the changes are
also saved to disk.
Over in variables.CSS,
I have my change here.
My big CSS was recompiled, and
then, of course, my JavaScript
change here, too.
So all this is
persisted to disk,
and I'm pretty happy with it.
So I'm just going to get commit.
So good.
OK.
I'm not going-- because who
wants that thing to happen?
That's just crazy.
All right.
Cool.
Let's come on back now.
All right.
So the DevTools
support for Sass that I
showed you is not Sass-specific.
It's generalized
for anything that
outputs source maps in CSS.
Less, just added
this in Less 1.5.
In fact, here's a quick
video of this in action.
This is a little
bootstrap page coming in.
And what we do is we just
select the well in bootstrap.
And when you see
it's a Less file,
we're going to Command click
just like we did before,
apply a little darken
function and hit Save.
The recompile happens.
We bring in the new CSS, and
you get to go really fast.
I also know that
work is happening
to bring source maps to
Autoprefixer, to Compass,
and I hear rumors about
Stylus considering it as well.
So all this paints a really
nice picture of DevTools
giving me a lot of
powerful features
when it comes to editing and
authoring and iterating fast.
All my changes can
be saved to disk.
I can be editing Sass and
Less and getting those updates
directly.
I can be editing anything,
really, in this project-- C++,
Markdown, the whole thing.
This also means that
if I'm authoring here
inside the DevTools, I can
also be placing breakpoints.
This is really nice.
I hit breakpoints.
I find my bug.
I fix it.
I hit Command S,
and V8 immediately
gets that new thing.
I then see that the bug
is gone, and I'm all good.
I never had to refresh
the page at all.
So I get the nice live edit
revaluation right on the fly.
If you make a mistake and
you don't want that change,
Command Z all your way back.
It works everywhere.
And I can do all this
while I'm remote debugging.
It's the same powerful
feature set on the phone.
So a lot of what I
showed today is new-ish.
And, in fact, there's
a brand new beta
for Chrome and Android,
Version 32, shipping today.
So I encourage you
to grab that if you
want to be able to replicate
everything that I showed.
And, of course, everything is
moving very fast on desktop.
The mobile emulation
features that I
showed have been landing
over the past few weeks.
And there's some great stuff,
so definitely grab Chrome Canary
and check out the latest
and greatest there.
And I was putting together
this presentation,
and I took a step back, and
I just had this Keanu moment.
And I was just like, whoa.
Because I was like, I
now have this insight
as to what are the actual GPU
characteristics on the phone,
and I can see that happening.
These things I didn't
even show-- this
is a flame chart of the
JavaScript evaluation
of a WebGL experience.
And I can see what my most
expensive functions are
and quickly drill into
that, very quickly,
or do a canvas or WebGL
profile and gain insight
into the characteristics
of how that's executing.
It's a lot going on.
This is moving fast.
But all in all, it's
giving you a lot
of insight in how to
make user experiences
across multiple devices that
are fluid, fast, and awesome.
So a lot of this is documented
at devtools.chrome.com.
I encourage you
to check that out.
And, please, if
you have any bugs,
feature requests, anything for
the DevTools, holler at me.
Just let me know.
I'll make it happen.
I'll do my best.
And thank you, guys, very much.
[APPLAUSE]